thank you for staying with us here at 6
30. i'm denise valdez and i'm joined by
bianca holman and brian loftus for this
30-minute special
joining us to talk about these issues is
our panel we have captain yaz yatomi
from metro's internal oversight
and constitutional policing bureau
roxanne mccoy
who is the president of the las vegas
naacp
chapter and kennedy cobin richardson who
is a diversity equity and inclusion
consultant with tension
thank you brian so once the video of
george floyd's death went viral
demonstrations erupted across the
country world
and right here in las vegas i was able
to speak with community organizers who
were on the front lines of the movement
about last year
and what they're doing now
several nights of demonstrations along
the las vegas strip
and friedman street feelings of
frustration songwriter and artist iam
truestar remembers the moment he saw the
video that shocked the world
it stopped me in my tracks just like
everybody else hurt me just like
everybody else
but it was a familiar pain truestar says
it felt like mike brown and eric gardner
all over again
so he connected with others true star
along with friends planned a march for
peace at city hall on june 3
2020. it was an intimate conversation
with metro officers centered around
policing
and the killing of unarmed black people
are you upset with what you've seen
that's what i asked everybody at the
heads of metro everybody in that room
was
pretty much disgusted with what they see
so if you're disgusted like i'm
disgusted that's a problem
that you guys have to fix the world
fought a deadly virus
more than 15 million people filled the
streets of hundreds of cities across
the world speaking out against injustice
and racism
there were some arrests metro police
blamed outside agitators and not
protesters for damage and violence in
las vegas
community organizers who've been in the
valley for years led many of the
uprisings
groups like black lives matter unlv and
mass liberation were boots
on the ground let's not just say because
people are at home with the pandemic
it's because there's a lot of young kids
who are like
i'm not tolerating this that's that
jinzy and those millennials
the people who are tired of this people
like uh
las vegas liberation and more than a
hashtag there was success unifying those
wanting to create a better society
but activists also say at times their
message was misrepresented
and feel there was over militarization
of law enforcement the wrong narrative
is pushed as far as you know that people
don't have the right to respond in the
way that we do
the wrong narrative is put out that you
know it's just violence
thug demonstrations are not as frequent
but work
is happening activists continue to
educate and build the movement through
programs social media and legislation
since then there have been more
organizations that have reached out that
want presentations want us to work
specifically with youth there has been a
bigger uptake with youth wanting to be
involved and have skills
to really be invested in community and
and make these changes happen
how do we lead the way how do we get in
our community what does that look like
what can we come up with we have
resources we have assets we have the
people it's just organizing it and
putting it to use
[Music]
spoke with leslie turner from mass
liberation she was able to connect me
with the ladies that you saw in that
story there was so much more
information that we definitely wanted to
add from her and them as well
and they tell us they've been doing the
work they're on the front lines of
social justice movement
to improve las vegas brian as bianca
pointed out the last year
set off a lot of protests and discussion
organizers of those protests
said a lot of work needs to still be
done there were a few changes within
metro's department itself
both when it's okay for them to use
deadly force and banning the use of
certain types of neck restraints
let's begin with captain yatomi captain
do you think those have had an impact
so far and are there other changes being
considered
well i'd like to start off by saying
there is no room at
las vegas metro foreign officer like
derek chovin
so like the gentleman in your special
noted
we were all shocked so reference the
policies there have been
numerous policy changes and yes they are
working
and it's important to note that we
haven't seen riots like this since 1992
with the roman king
so needless to say we saw protests
ranging from anywhere from six people to
5 000
um anybody who's been in this community
for any amount of time
know that that is a very unusual site we
have never seen it before we were not
prepared for such large protests
so we did a lot of learning along the
way and our policies
were changed our policies were changed
to reflect those
those types of protests that are large
and not to mention
what we had normally dealt with were
protests involving
organized uh labor unions we we had
connection with the labor organizers
that were
organizing the events this was a little
different we didn't have that readily
available there were organizing
uh entities that did not want to speak
with las vegas metro
there were others that did and at the
end of the day
our officers existed to protect those
that are out there
peacefully protesting that was that is
our job
so unfortunately when they escalated to
riots on
that that silence the message that
some that were uh lawfully assembling it
silenced their message
so we did evolve we increased and
enhanced the understanding of
what a protest is a lawful assembly
versus a riot
disorder within those ranks we also
clarified language for
our officers um when we disclosed or
distributed dispersal orders we
increased the amount of times we
we notified those of dispersal orders
and we also
enhanced those dispersal orders to come
from many multiple directions again
we're dealing with
approximately 5 000 protesters out there
one area
and one microphone was not doing the
trick so we enhanced our
protest policy in those in that fashion
and captain i want to point out for our
entire panel we're going to talk more
about protests a little bit later but
to really stick with use of force
roxanne mccoy now do you think the
changes roxanne
with use of force policy have gone far
enough
have you seen them have an impact
absolutely i have and thank you for
having us here tonight
um i think this is a really important
conversation
but um absolutely um the naacp
las vegas was very instrumental in the
changes
in metro's use of force policies
after the death of byron williams who
was killed
on a bicycle it gave us an opportunity
to go back and look at their body camera
footage to see a lot of things that
needed to be changed within their
policies and procedures
and so we were on the front lines of
talking with our police department to
say hey
there are some challenges here that need
to be changed in your use of force
policy
to include banning the chokehold the
duty to intervene
first aid intervention and putting
people in a position
and roxanne it looks like we just lost
your signal there we're going to
continue with kennedy kennedy the same
question for you
do you think changes
roxanne we're going to circle back when
we get your signal strong enough kennedy
do you think they've gone far enough and
have you seen them have an impact so
i also want to say thank you for having
us on and also i know that
that there are good cops out there who
are doing great work every day
and these policies are aligned so that
everyone can follow them
and so yes i have seen policies being
changed
even ahead of legislation still really
proud
of nevada for uh in august going into
special session
and getting legislation in so that
people can
have something to follow by however it
is just the beginning and so
we have to start somewhere but it'll be
the compliance really that
will really let us know how those laws
and rules and policy books are being
followed
there are approximately a thousand
people who die
from use of force um every year and
unfortunately in 2020 even during a
pandemic there were 1100 across the
united states
that died of use of force so even when
people are sheltering in place
i was disappointed to see that it didn't
decline
and in fact you know it was a little on
the high end based up with over 1100
deaths via police force and so
as long as that legislation or those
rule books um have
a a penalty a tied to it so that people
want to follow the rules we all know
about rules who are just simply not
enforced
they might as well be ignored and so the
answer to your question yes i do see
some changes and i see some positive
changes but there's more to come with
data to see whether or not
it's actually working a lot to unpack on
this issue
and we'll continue on the topic but now
denise
yeah and kennedy was touching on it
there are changes on the way
from the legislature in fact a couple
new laws were just signed today
so we're going to tell you what they do
and we'll also talk about if any
other changes are in the works that's
still ahead tonight on breaking down
barriers
this is 8 news now special edition
the george floyd justice and policing
act is a civil rights and
police reform bill drafted by democrats
in congress but it's been stalled
the goal is to combat police misconduct
excessive force
and racial bias and policing and so far
that bill really isn't going anywhere so
let's talk about some new laws actually
being created in nevada
that happened today one that the
governor signed allows the attorney
general's office to
do what they call pattern or practice
investigation
to see if an issue with law enforcement
is in an isolated action of just one
officer
or is it part of a larger systemic issue
the other that was passed today severely
limits no knock warrants all right
so before we went to break kennedy cobin
richardson
you were talking about some legislation
some laws so this one today
recognizing patterns if there are any uh
what's your reaction to that are we
moving in the right direction
uh thank you absolutely we're moving in
the right direction because
it is not just a few bad apples you know
sort of that are ruining the punch
um it is the sixth leading cause of
death
for young men uh for young men and so
that is a public health issue and so the
data again
shows you know that it is not just you
know a few guys who just don't know what
they're doing in the field
um but they are uh there there's many
people so for example
there's a hundred uh black men who are
out of a thousand who
will come into a fatal interco encounter
with uh the police
whereas for native americans is about 55
i'm out of a hundred thousand and for uh
white men 39
out of 100 000 so the data shows us that
there is a pattern um that it goes along
the
the lines of race age and sex
uh and hence certainly we need to uh
investigate those
and to see if in our town whether or not
we can do something about it
so roxanne we're talking about the data
there we see the numbers legislation
just passed today
is this something that the naacp says is
is going far enough
do we even go more forward i
think that it's a start but we still
have we still have to continue to move
it forward
this is not nearly enough this is just
only the beginning because we're just
starting to address this issue
and as kennedy said that um amongst
african-americans is the sixth leading
cause of death and so we're just
beginning this process and i like the
direction in which it's going right now
captain yaz you want to chime in here
yes and one thing i'd like to mention
too
is i do believe that there needs to be
consistent data collection
across different law enforcement
agencies as you know we're not all
created equal
they're different amounts of officers
per department the leadership is
different
and and listen i couldn't agree more
with inviting the ag's office
into our investigations we're an
organization that is not afraid
of progressive change we're very used to
it actually
as you know we're one of the biggest one
of the largest larger agencies that
welcome body cams first
um we appreciate it it's priceless to us
now
we welcome it and then just for that
progressive our sheriff is very
committed to
transparency and being progressive in
our policy and changing
they will always change our policy will
continually evolve it's a
it's an organic organism if you will but
what i'd like to also mention is
we've had two officer-involved shootings
and the last two we've actually reached
out and invited the ag's office to
attend
our critical briefings our fit
investigation briefings
and they've attended that's in including
with the da's office the presentation we
do to our executive staff
the da's office is present and the ag's
office has also attended the last two
just one today as a matter of fact we've
also invited them to the crime scene
the scene of the officer involved
shooting the night of
so again uh very proud of our
organization and our ability to
welcome change we're not afraid of it we
welcome it and um hopefully this isn't
anything new this isn't politicized
we're doing it just the beginning of
lots of positive steps toward working
with the community and becoming more
transparent all right ladies thank you
bianca all right
a summer of uprisings so what did we
learn up next on breaking down barriers
we'll ask our panel about the way police
deal with large-scale protests
and what changes need to happen news now
special edition during many of the
demonstrations last year in downtown
or along the strip we saw heavy force
being used from tear gas rubber bullets
many people being arrested it was very
traumatizing for them
some activists just recently getting an
update a year later
i was in the arts the review journal
today
um because my case just closed on the
20th
there is like i said 255 people arrested
and only one in four cases were open
and i'm just closed and so let's start
with uh captain yaz here
what lessons and you kind of touched on
this a little bit earlier did metro
learn from last year
any policy changes that the protesters
are going to see going forward
and also again the connection and
communication with some of the younger
organizations
uh that again are trying to make change
here in las vegas captain
of course and as i said before the
policy has already been changed in fact
we changed it in
august of 2020. um so a lot of those
changes involved
um and you know i want to mention we did
lean
on our mac committee our multicultural
advisory committee
for a lot of advice and feedback on
those changes um
but some of the changes that we
instituted again strengthening the
language of our policy so our officers
were equipped with how to properly
respond um dealing with legal advisors
and how
we are to interact with them and the one
thing that i can't
you know detract from enough is the
importance
to engage with the organizers that is a
constant effort we don't just give up
if we can't get a hold of somebody it's
a constant effort throughout the
protests or throughout the event
that we are going to continually uh
reach out we also
retrained our entire police force on
mobile field force which is just
the recreation of a large capacity
gathering
and so we better equip our officers on
how to respond in those circumstances
so we made a lot of efforts into
how that policy has changed
strengthening definitions and how
supervisors are accountable for the
tactics in the field
to engaging with the protest organizers
and also legal observers present and
those changes have already been made and
that was made back
in august like i said all right kennedy
let's ask you next about how metro deals
with protests
your thoughts my thoughts i really had a
great opportunity to ride in a protest
all the way down the strip with the
quiet storm
and we were escorted by the police
and that was really my first time being
so close in contact you know with that
many police in a positive way
and so i was happy that and i could tell
that some things had shifted you know
even in policy by the way they
interacted and
and begrudging you know took a picture
with us later and so i appreciated that
on the flip side i also have a colleague
um who is a lawyer um and just waiting
um for an uber
to uh be picked up after uh the protest
was you know
forcefully you know put on the ground
hands behind and it was a scene that
i i it's really traumatizing quite
honestly
and so again um these things you know we
can talk about the good side but there
still is that side that still needs to
be managed
um and people need to be managed and
again that accountability
um needs to be there and so from a
protest standpoint
you know i had a good experience but i
have people in my life
that did not have a good experience and
while that's anecdotal
um some of that just doesn't need to
happen at all right
and we are a little bit short on time so
roxanne we're going to hear from you a
little bit later
again we definitely want to hear your
thoughts about this because of course
the naacp has been a part of
demonstrations
throughout throughout history we're
going to send over to denise
all right and still ahead tonight
recruiting a more diverse
force up next we'll talk about what
efforts are being made to have a police
force that represents the community it
works in
breaking down barriers we'll be right
back special edition
we are going to wrap up our discussion
here but we're going to continue it on
our website to talk about diversity
recruiting efforts
within law enforcement a lot of other
issues as well in fact there was a study
released earlier this year by the
american association for the advancement
of science
and it suggests that diversity in law
enforcement can
indeed lead to improvements in how
police treat people
of color but how do we get a police
force that better represents what we
look like
here is what one protest organizer
suggested
community policing you've got to have
the people that were born in those
neighborhoods
policing those neighborhoods right
because they understand the people they
understand the
way things are in that community and
they can serve them better
actually serve them and protect them
right and those police
will feel a duty to protect and serve
them because they're from that community
it's a connection both ways
well thank you for switching over from
eight news now on tv and joining us on
eight news now dot com
we wanted to circle back with roxanne
mccoy and get a little bit more
information from her on her answer
regarding protest denise
all right yeah we were talking about
protests and how far we've come how the
reaction has been to that so let's bring
back in roxanne mccoy right now
to give you that last word we weren't
able to do it while we were still on
channel 8 roxanne
thank you um i think that lvnpd
has really did a decent job in
what they did in terms of their protest
policy because i think the protests were
so
rapid and moving so fast that it gave
them an opportunity
throughout the protest to pivot and kind
of like
change direction figure out what was
working well what wasn't working well
and to be able to make sure that they
manage the crowd
a little bit better a lot friendlier um
but making sure that they held law and
order
at the same time and so i think that it
was just an evolution of the protest
as to how i think that their protest
policy came about and i thought that in
the end that it was very effective
i think there's some improvement that
can always be done on things
and we will learn those things as we are
more involved in them
and get the opportunity to experience
them as we have
but prior to that i don't know that
we've experienced protests
on that large a scale that we did during
the george floyd murder incident um last
summer
and it gave us an opportunity to really
learn a lot from it and figure out the
things that worked and those that did
not
all right so that kind of transitions us
into what we're going to be talking
about which is
diversity when it comes to recruitment
and i know
captain yaz there's been a huge effort
in the last couple of years
to recruit more officers but
specifically more officers of color
more women because it the studies have
panned out that
women typically will use less force when
they're dealing with
uh people in the field and also a people
of color
may not necessarily go immediately to
excessive force
so what's your reaction to just getting
more people who look like us
on the on the police force you know we
absolutely want our police force to
represent
our community i couldn't agree more than
the
artist that was interviewed in the field
when he says hey listen
when you have people from the community
in your police force
policing the people of a community you
can't help but have a better outcome
with how they interact
um but our sheriff has not only
made recruitment efforts in the last
three years it's been ever since
i can remember we have
um recruitment councils we have african
american recruitment councils we have
lgbtq
uh recruitment councils hispanic council
in fact we just had an event this last
um it was actually on
if i can remember here correctly the
first
which was at the boulevard mall and the
other thing to that is we have to go
to them as well it's not something where
we see that maybe is sought out so much
but if we make it personal if we go to
them
if we make it to where we're more
familiar that's an effort that we're
willing to make
i remember when i was the captain over
at bolden area command and one of the
things that i took great pride in was i
actually went to
matt kelly elementary and brought the
students over for a field day
the students should be at our police
station it shouldn't just be a building
it should be something that's accessible
to them something that they can actually
envision themselves working at it's no
different than if you know you take your
kid to work day and you happen to
you know work at a bank that might be
something that you know introduces
that person that child to something that
they can feel
they have access to it it is a reality
and a possibility that they could
if so should they choose that profession
so those are some of the things but the
efforts to recruit
individuals to represent our agency to
represent the community
absolutely first and foremost a priority
for our agency and our sheriff and it
makes that career so much more
approachable
for young kids so um kennedy let's bring
in you and
just as to remind our viewers you
specialize in diversity
equity and inclusion when it comes to
recruitment so this is right up your
alley i mean you probably been
monitoring how are we doing with that
maybe not just not necessarily just
metro but how are we doing with
henderson and north las vegas as well
yes it's interesting because i have
worked directly with metro henderson
and north las vegas for nearly a decade
and so this hasn't you know so even
before george floyd there has been a
focus on hiring women and minorities
into the force
and yaz has it correct when you need to
start at the elementary level
because what i found trying to recruit
someone right now who's 18 to 21 or
older
um they already have an opinion about
what the police force is
and quite honestly it's a career in
crisis so they don't have the greatest
respect
um or admiration let alone wanting to
become one
and so there is a time you know where i
remember a time when
um most first responders were heroes and
so we really have to start and had we
started say
we had a fifth grade class right now or
who did it back
uh in 2011 when i started right now
ah i wanted to hear your thought there
kennedy about reaching some of these
younger kids let's see if we can get
your signal back
but uh roxanne you've probably been
listening how important it is to for
this diversity recruitment but we're
kind of shifting gears we're talking
about reaching younger kids
exactly exactly so we just want to uh
make sure that we we were able to
promote the profession early on
and oh am i still there yep a little bit
and to make sure that we're building
community trust the reason why having
somebody from the community
become a police person is because that
trust is there and so establishing that
trust is first and foremost and starting
early
is next roxanne i'm sure you have an
opinion on this
yeah i agree 100 with both ladies and as
being part of metro's multitasking
culture advisory council
it is always at the forefront of our
conversation on how do we recruit
more african-americans within our police
department
and i think that for the naacp that
comes down to building
trust and relationships the relationship
between the police and the black
community is has a negative connotation
to it
most of the time when we encounter the
police it's always
negatively somebody's being taken away
somebody's being arrested
or somebody's being killed so what we've
been working on this past summer
is working with the police foundation to
do just what kennedy was talking about
is engage our youth
at a much earlier age to start building
relationship between
our young students and our police
department and we're starting
this program in elementary school but
we're going to make sure that we're
touching elementary school
our middle school and our high school
students because until we start building
those relationships then we're never
going to change
our mindset on policing being a positive
attribute
versus a negative one that we always see
and so we're trying to work to change
that mindset and build relationships
organically much younger so we've
touched a little bit on recruitment
now let's touch a little bit more on
retention keeping those officers and
brian's going to talk more about that
yeah on that note denise sheriff joe
lombardo said last week on our morning
cup of joe segment on the morning show
that more and more officers are actually
leaving the force take a listen we are
seeing an increase
not similar to other jurisdictions but
we've seen a slight
increase we have usually around 175
separations a year here at metro
this last year we had an additional 60
so that's nothing to sneeze at or cough
at or
just ignore because that's a big number
so let's continue on with that issue and
essentially getting your reaction in
terms of retention let's begin with you
roxanne
and talk about the the need to retain
police officers
from what i understand and i'm not sure
um
exactly this is but we want to retain
the good police officers
um the bad police officers we're okay
that they want to leave
because they're uncomfortable because
they're going to be held accountable and
held to a standard now especially with
policies and procedures changing
and so i'm okay with the bad officers
leaving but we have to continue to
replace them
with the good officers and making sure
that the officers that are doing right
want to stay want to feel like they're
welcome there
and that they could be a part of the
change and so
for me personally i'm okay with the bad
officers leaving but we do have to make
sure
that we maintain the good ones so that
we can continue to recruit
good ones captain you told me how do we
do that with so many uh
good hard-working police officers of the
force how do we retain those officers
per the point of roxanne well first of
all i couldn't agree more with roxanne
um and you know we we want to retain
officers that want
to be here and want to perform and serve
their community to the best of our
ability
right so how do we retain our officers
you know
um the the passion to do this job
goes beyond the paycheck i need to be
very very clear about that
so in order to retain officers
in our agency we continue to just do the
work
the work that they hired on to do every
morning
officers put on their uniform and i
agree with again roxanne with
what her comment was was maybe some
officers are afraid to change
um and like the sheriff said you know
it's the
amount of officers retiring isn't
exponential like
some agencies are experiencing and that
is because
our officers are very accustomed to
change and i have to point that out
um this organization changed the 22
years that i've been on this department
it has changed over and over and over
again our policy manual does not look
the same as it did five years ago
and five years from now our policy
manual will undoubtedly look different
once again it continually changes and i
think as an organization we're very used
to that
our officers are very used to new things
that we incorporate
first something that we learn from
lessons
um exam for example like these protests
that we've experienced
there's a lot of lessons learned and
again yet again
change was implemented we're very used
to that and i think that is one reason
why we are able to retain some officers
um because they're not they're not
there's not a shell shock
to that to those changes that we
incorporate and often
kennedy as you hear that answer from the
captain how important
is it to have that positive change
within the department and also
piggybacking the previous question
the effort to retain those good police
officers
and increase more of that on the force
yeah i think that's
ultra important and to yaz's point
becoming a police officer is more than
just a good idea it's
something that you have to be extremely
passionate about
and want to do good in the community
and i think that i you know the couple
joke uh that you played
it didn't say why they were leaving um
and perhaps it is retirement
um or perhaps it is you know just
getting too hard out there
um and no longer want to take those
risks i'm not sure what the reasons are
however i do believe if people are ready
to go this is a career that you should
go
right this is not the career you want to
be tired um
or just fed up with you kind of want to
have a good idea
about or a good good feeling about what
you're doing as
teachers and other careers that really
have an impact on the community
and so from a retention standpoint in my
mind i wondered whether or not it would
have to do with the
the qualified immunity that you know is
going
or should be taken away you know when uh
people are
charged with misconduct and you know not
having sort of
a way to escape penalty when things do
go wrong and that person is charged or
is wrong
and so i'm not sure what the reasons are
however
uh to rock stan's point we definitely
want to keep the good ones
and keep them happy and and being used
to change should be a part of the job
and being
a good cop and wanting to serve the
community has to be a passion
you know that they arrive to every
single day
well said by all kennedy roxanne captain
thank you for
your expertise on these issues and now
over to bianca
all right thanks brian well the number
of hr diversity equity and
inclusion jobs at businesses across the
country has doubled
the job search website classdoor says
the number one concern for hr executives
is making sure diversity equity and
inclusion is at the top
concern with employees returning at 82
percent that even beats cobit 19 related
changes at 71
kennedy this is your industry so
definitely let's start with you
i'm sure you see this as a positive tell
us why
certainly that is a positive um and i
i do see it requests you know are
overwhelming quite honestly
um and also it's really important that
people are doing it for the right
reasons and i will say that that is what
i have seen
people really want to understand they
want to know how they can be better and
be part of the solution
rather than part of the problem but that
is a long-term process again just like
recruitment this is a strategy that we
have to be committed to
long wind this passion you know um is
not so hot right and so today it's
it's really important um that people
realize that you know they have a
10-year commitment
um to really focusing on what's going on
because we're dealing with really
emotional issues
and how people grew up right and so the
fact that
um the race specifically is a category
where we're trying to categorize human
value with blacks with no value and
whites at maximum value and everyone
else in between
with more or less value and so when a
policeman
reaches a 15 year old black boy
and and says that his life is you know
doesn't matter then that's why
there are more or when you're hiring
and you don't call the resume that says
jamal johnson but you do call brad
connor
and those are all data driven uh facts
that happen
or you call joe and not jose and so
the reality is we have to get to things
that really don't make us feel good
about ourselves
um even though if it's implicit and we
just we don't know that we're doing it
but it's a commitment to be a part of
the solution and realize that the
american dream can only be accomplished
if we all do it together um and so dei
consultants are on the job
really trying to change that one company
at a time yeah roxanne same question to
you uh definitely want to have you weigh
in
and what are your thoughts regarding
this um i agree 100
with um what kennedy was just saying is
that
the conversation is long overdue
conversation
and something that needed to be needed
to have been taking place
in the workplace for a long time i think
for a long time people were
uncomfortable to have the conversation
and now they're forced to have the
conversation
because in order to progress us as a
people of human beings
to go to the next level we have to
figure out how to be inclusive of
everyone
and sometimes we encounter people that
we don't quite understand their culture
their background
their race at all and so dni
d and i comes into play really really
significantly during those times so that
we can just
understand and be more tolerant and be a
part of the solution
and it isn't just an overnight fix we
can't just be
a buzzword for the moment it has to be
something that they're going to be
committed to
long term and really be a part of the
change that they're hoping to see
and it's going to be a commitment
organization
that company that's going to be ongoing
every day
so we know this is happening in several
different industries but captain
how is this reflected in police
departments
so i want to go back to our diversity
and recruiting efforts
i think that might just go ahead and put
the
sherry on top with our commitment and
our efforts
you know like kennedy said you know
you're looking at certain applications
and maybe you called john smith instead
of
um right but let me tell you we're
looking for the diversity we just
graduated 88 officers
this afternoon and i'm happy to say that
those efforts
in that class are reflected we are
looking for women we are looking for
minorities we are looking for
you know those that would reflect a
diverse uh a diverse culture for our
agency
but more importantly we're looking for
qualifications
because at the end of the day they need
to perform regardless if they're a man
or a woman
whatever they identify with the
expectation is that they that they
perform
they serve our community as we expect
them to serve our community
so but i do want to say our commitment i
i'd like to go back to our recruiting
efforts
um you know they didn't just we didn't
just begin them yesterday
it's been an ongoing effort and we
continually are committed
to that effort um and i and listen i
i've had a very successful 22-year
career so far
um and and um i owe that to this
organization being committed to those
efforts
for sure and again you know again once
the diverse staff is hired people want
to feel valued those conversations
continue like you said you got to be
dedicated to the long haul
and of course retaining that amazing
diverse talent we're going to send it
over to denise
i have to say that you know recruiting
graduating
88 officers during a pandemic is already
a pretty big
accomplishment so well done to metro for
that and you know
captain you were talking earlier it has
to be more than just a paycheck it has
to be a passion
so that kind of leads us to our next
question is
you know you find a good officer they're
on the force but how do you make sure
that there really
are a good fit for you i mean how do you
monitor them maybe they have bias that
you're not aware of i mean
can we go beyond just monitoring their
social media
how do we find out what they're doing
outside of the office that might reflect
what they might do when they're wearing
the uniform
that's the whole another segment
there's so i think you're opening up a
can of water from laughing
kennedy that's a that's a whole other
news segment right um
there are so many factors that go into
policing um and let me just talk about
one and that's the human element yeah
um we do hire from our community and
there's a human element
yes i can talk about you know our
employee performance
you know eat we call it eat um and and
you know it kind of
uses statistics and data and how much
you know how many times an officer has
been in trouble but we all know that
each of those circumstances they're
unique they're different
i mean we've done i i oh my goodness we
had almost 1.5 million
calls for service that's a lot of calls
for service so to take one person
and try to categorize them and and
average them out
it's very hard when you're dealing with
a human element there's leadership
involved as well you know
what kind of leadership do those
officers
are they exposed to you know what kind
of past history experience do they have
you know young officers i'm sure you
know there's some officers in the street
that i even see they
i don't know if they don't even look 21
but they're coming from a generation
that is um it's challenging right you
you can bring up the technology aspect
of it and how they communicate to
um individuals that are senior to them
in the field um
again 1.5 million calls for service
that's a lot and
it's it's the variety of what we
interact with
um you know that that's that's a
difficult question but
i'll tell you there's there's a human
element that that poses a challenge
um and yes our department does have uh
you know statistical data programs in
place to help
flag or preemptively flag maybe a
problem officer
um and then you know at face value it
might look horrible but when you peel
back the layers and you look at each
in individual incident um you know
there's no
there's there's really no black and
white
to it you've got to look deeper you've
got to say okay well you know was he
exposed to critical incidents what
caused this
you know what type of incident is
flagging is it a car accident versus a
community complaint um like i said
many factors go into that and it's it's
and and it's um
but it's something that our agency is
very much aware of and we do
make proactive efforts on finding them
before
finding problems before they happen and
it could be as simple as
you've been in three car accidents we
have a problem what is that problem look
like
you've had three use of forces within a
month that might be a problem
where is that stemming from what are the
circumstances of those use of forces
so as you can see and then we factor in
the experience of the officer and the
time on that they've had versus
a one-year officer's perception versus a
20-year officer perception versus a
10-year officer possession there's um
there's a lot of factors that go into
monitoring an officer's successful
career and how they perform with the
community so
roxanne i mean you know people are
people right you hire who you think is
the best person
do you think that maybe some extra extra
step should be taken to make sure that
there isn't bias there isn't something
going on outside their life that they
might bring into the office
um i'm sure there should be extra steps
but i have to say
honestly that we all come into
everything with biases
right at the end of the day it's how
we're going to manage those biases in
our professional lives
and so people are going to come in there
with biases and if we're looking for
people that don't have any
then we're not being realistic because
as you ass said we have the human factor
that we have to
incorporate in there and so with us
having those
bias i think that if we do see those
flags and there are things that we make
sure that are in place that if
something's standing out that if they
have significant use of forces
it's like hey there's a problem here
there's those things that are taking
place
toward a certain group of people and
we're saying okay wait a minute let me
pay
closer attention to this and when we
recognize those biases i think what's
going to be really really important
is that there's accountability
associated with right
because a lot of times we realize the
biases
there's no accountability associated
with it and then the biases are just
left to just linger and continue on and
cause more harm
so kennedy you deal with this you you
recruit people all the time they're
putting their best face forward but
there is some accountability when it
comes to that are we doing enough
there's there's there's only so much we
can do before a person is
uh hired you know a part of a company
unfortunately
however there are a few things one you
know people can
be really good in an interview so not
taking the police because that's a long
longer process but in other professions
people can be really good in an
interview and one of the things
that is a little bit more reliable is
the background check
and talking to references and so if you
can get someone on the phone that will
tell you beyond you know the days they
work
salary and their title but really get
into the person that that helps out
quite a bit
um and then if you find some people who
have some challenges in their background
you know to one allow them the
opportunity
to speak to it but then two to realize
you know that you may have to make a
different decision you know if it's
worth
taking on a person who has a history
of perhaps bias in the workplace
particularly those with power
so those who are heads vice presidents
captains leadership leadership is
important
and if there's anything that i would say
is most important
in weeding out uh would be leadership
for sure
accountability and leadership all right
right now i'm going to toss over to
bianca for a final word with our
panelists tonight
all right well we want to thank you all
for joining us and we want to give each
of our panelists
a final word captain yesenia you told me
from metro's internal oversight and
constitutional policing bureau
go ahead and go first or final word i'll
tell you that listen
um organization is committed to
transparency
um we will make every effort to continue
that our sheriff has been very clear
he's committed to that
and um i have to say that i appreciate
having the opportunity to be on the show
to actually discuss with my colleagues
and peers and
and one thing that won't stop for our
agency is the continual
seeking of feedback from the community
and we hope that
we provide the services that are
expected you know i i'm very proud of
the organization
and and happy to be here thank you
kennedy cobin
richardson who is a diversity equity and
inclusion consultant
and uh go ahead new share so i want to
say thanks again as well
i know that the occasion is the
anniversary of george floyd
and there have been some really positive
things that happened and i just like to
say that because we don't want his death
to be in vain you know legislation was
passed it sparked a global conversation
um the blm black lives matter movement
has been reignited
police agencies and unions have changed
even ahead of legislation
um and that there's lots of justice for
the family of
of the floyd family and i just believe
that we are
on the right track and that everyone
is involved and so i hope that that we
continue this track together
um blacks whites asians latinos everyone
because justice
anywhere is justice everywhere and so or
everywhere is just as anywhere so i
appreciate
the opportunity to celebrate his life in
this way thank you thank you
roxanne mccoy president of the las vegas
naacp chapter
final thoughts again on this anniversary
of george floyd's death and
what we've learned um thank you
for having me here and i appreciate the
opportunity to
have conversation with my peers here as
well
um i think that we are moving in the
right direction
there is always work to be done and i
appreciate
and respect the fact that we are
continuing to evolve that we're not
content to be
in one spot that we recognize that a
tragedy took place to ignite this nation
to want to move and that that fire
continues to stay lit
in all of us we just don't take this as
a moment in time
i think we may have lost the connection
there
uh but again and that's going to take
all of us it's going to take our
community
go ahead you can you can finish uh
roxanne it's
our community it's going to take our
police department it's going to take our
businesses all working collaboratively
together
to say what can we do to make our
community
the best community that we can make it
and i look forward to that opportunity
to be able to work with everyone in
doing so
so thank you definitely thank you so
much well again ladies thank you for
taking time out this evening to have
this conversation with us
and again be sure that you have our app
downloaded and again this information
will be available on our website
and brian denise again we want to say
thank you
have a great evening
you